why did god choose abraham was it
because of his obedience or was it
god's grace that made him to obey if i answer
let me pray father in heaven that's an excellent
question i believe the other one is also good give
me some biblical wisdom to answer so that you're
represented in my answer in jesus name i pray
amen if you read joshua 24 the first three verses
god told the israelites i took your father abraham
from the other side of the flood abraham lived on
one side of the euphrates river and the bible
says that the family of abraham served other
gods but abraham did not abraham was faithful to
god even before god gave the special call to him
of course no one can obey god without god's grace
because when you talk about obeying god you're
talking about obeying a law that is divine and
a divine law cannot be kept by a carnal person
it is by the power of christ and
so abraham had been faithful to god
and god looked around and you know elohim says
after the dispersal from canaan or from babel
the world the idolatry again became well
not universal so god virtually found just
one faithful family on the earth and that was
a family headed by abraham and god called him
so abraham obeyed yes by the help of god because
you must have heavily helped to obey a heavenly
law no earthly person can obey a divine law to
god's satisfaction it's absolutely impossible why
because romans 8 verse 7 says because
the carnal mind is enmity against god
for it is not subject to the law of
god in other words it does not obey
that's why the ethiopian cannot change his
skin the leopard cannot change his thoughts
you see yes it is by the power of god
anyone obeys god but abraham demonstrated
a faithfulness to god and god chose him to work
through his family but to reach the whole world
because genesis 12 3 god that verse ends with
this and in thee shall all families of the earth
be blessed and in acts 3 25 26 that blessing
is the gospel salvation from sins repressed